bonjour Vincent Cassel alors vous êtes
Atos dans le deuxième volet des Trois
Mousquetaires qui va sortir le 13
décembre prochain le premier avait été
un succès énorme plus de 3 millions de
spectateurs et évidemment tout le monde
attend la suite avec impatience et on
vous a réuni aujourd'hui avec Cédric
Cédric vous êtes multiples champion du
monde de kickboxing et aujourd'hui vous
faites du MMA on se souvient de votre
premier combat victorieux pour le PFL
cette année à Paris et vous réunir tous
les deux aujourd'hui au sommet de votre
art vous êtes des champions dans vos
disciplines respectives donc bah voilà
c'est le bonheur de vous avoir
aujourd'hui sur brut on a un casting
fabuleux comment on fait pour durer
aussi longtemps et enchaîner les succès
comment on fait pour dire c'est la
question que je te pose comment on fait
pour durer aussi longtemps c'est pas
exactement la même
technique c'est vraiment très différent
pour le coup parce que là dans ce que je
fais moi il y a pas de champion en fait
c'est pas une compétition dans
l'absolu l'entraement untit peu comment
il y a de l'entraînement quand
même je sais pas oui on Fa il faut jouer
il faut apprendre à jouer mais c'est
même ça c'est on l'apprend plus je suis
pas sûr que M je suis même pas sûr que
ça send vraiment dans un cours où il y a
pas de condition physique il y a pas de
c'est vraiment c'est pas du sport le
cinéma je crois pas en en tout cas moi
je le vois pas du tout comme ça je vois
plutôt comme un jeu éventuellement mais
plus comme un jeu de poker à ce momentl
où il y a du bluff où on on joue des
cartes on fait semblant de d'être au top
alors qu'on l'est pas on accepte des
projets on les refuse moi je dirais
qu'il y a une capacité d'adaptation
quand même c'est ça qui fait que bah par
exemple toi dans ta carrière c'est on te
connaî tous pour ton rôle culte dans la
haine aujourd'hui TR mousquetaire toute
façon adaptation c'est la survie dans le
cinéma auss peut-être une adaptation à
une époque on sait que tout va très vite
c'est sûr que ça a changé on regarde
plus les images de la même manière
aujourd'hui il y a plein de gens qui
regardent des films ou des
séries chez eux vont moins au cinéma
comme on sait mais il y a aussi le fait
que je crois que la capacité de
concentration des gens a vachement
baissé en fait on a besoin de voir des
choses courtes avec des trucs de TikTok
de d'insta de stories et ce on regarde
et puis on a besoin d'avoir un plaisir
direct tout de suite et après si ça trop
longtemps et que ça devient un peu
complexe pour pas dire compliqué on a
autre chose à [__] alors que peut-être
pas d'ailleurs mais en tout cas on a
l'impression d'avoir autre chose à
[__] le côté court 9 secondes aussi la
dernière fois c'était çaidée pas
critiquer la consommation rapide pas une
stie quoi c'est mon fond de commerce
plus comb court mieux c'est et même moi
ça me fait penser à mon à mon précédent
combat où je vais switcher entre le mec
qui va divertir et je dois rester quand
même dans mon rôle de combattant je sors
du combat je rentre je reviens dans le
combat c'est assez c'est une press que
tout le monde n'est pas capable de de
faire est-ce que vous êtes parfois en
proie au doute et comment vous avez fait
l'un et l'autre pour le surmonter
clairement B le doute il coûte plus cher
dans ton cas quand même j'ai
l'impression
he après j'ai je sais pas si c'est
pareil pour toi mais moi j'ai besoin de
ce doute c'estd extérieurement on voit
quelqu'un de confiant je vais te mettre
KO je vais te battre je suis le meilleur
et cetera mais intérieurement c'est une
bataille entre moi et moi-même c'est et
je pense que j'ai besoin de ça pour
performer on a besoin de cette mini peur
de ce stress qui va ser servir de
carburant en fait finalement pour pour
sortir une prouesse ouais de se
retrouver dans une situation où on n'est
pas complètement en contrôle ça je peux
le je l'ai aussi dans dans ce que je
fais c'est-à-dire que quand tu vas
attaquer un rôle bien souvent je ne sais
pas comment je vais me sortir de ce truc
je vais même te dire un truc quand je
vais attaquer une prise tu vois une
prise ou un plan tu es là tu fais [__]
c'est marrant je parlais de ça avec
quelqu'un c'estàd que c'est même
intéressant de voir les autres acteurs
quand tout d'un coup ils ont un gros
plan ou une scène où c'est vachement sur
eux et que tu es sur le plateau tu vois
je sais qu'à ce momentlà il est dans la
merde et donc ça m'intéresse vachement
de voir comment il va s'en sortir ouais
parce que c'est ça qui fait un peu la la
valeur et la qualité des gens tu vois
c'est de voir tu dis ok là il est dans
une situation il a ça de texte il a un
truc compliqué à jouer moi je suis un
peu hor champ là et je le regarde et ça
m'intéresse de voir comment il va sortir
de là au même titre que quand moi je
suis dans la merde j'assume complètement
je à ce momentl je suis tout seul mais
je sais qu'à la fin de la journée je
vais me sortir de la merde pour toi
c'est plus compliqué l' impro ou un
texte balaise j'ai envie de te dire que
même si tu as un texte balaise la vérité
c'est que c'est quand même de l'impro
parce que tu as le canva du texte mais
en fait ce que tu vas vivre au fur à
mesure des répliques c'est bah c'est ce
qui va se passer c'est ce que tu vas
percevoir c'est tu vois c'est on cherche
l'accident en fait quand on joue tu vois
si tout est exactement comme c'est écrit
ça n'a aucun intérêt alors justement
Vincent dans le film vous êtes un
mousquetaire du roi qui combat en duel
est-ce que le MMA aujourd'hui ce n'est
pas une forme très moderne de duel
est-ce que Athos aujourd'hui ferait du
MM1 alors si les Mousquetaires sont un
peu des brigades de l'État j'imagine que
les mecs aujourd'hui qui travaillent
dans les services secrets et cetera
doivent avoir même si c'est pas du MMA
en terme de sport mais en tout cas
doivent avoir une une formation qui
touche à ça que ça s'appelle le
penchacilac le CRAV Maga le Systema ou
ces trucl ça quand même c'est c'est
c'est des gens qui doivent pratiquer les
combats rapproché à maintenu de manière
efficace non
si c'est ça complètement ça c'est vrai
justement il y a cette rencontre
aujourd'hui parce que c'est l'un de vos
acteurs préférés oui attention est que
c'est lui qui a ten moi qui ten Cdric
non c'est vraim on pourrait se dire
ouais il dit ça parce qu'il est là non
non c'est vraiment vraiment l'un de mes
acteurs préférés et le cinéma vous ça
vous intéresse Cédric un peu un peu que
ça m'intéresse mon rêve c'est d'être
acteur à la base de base mon rêve
aujourd'hui encore c'est d'être acteur
de boxer je me souviens je enfin non
même pas en même temps je su boxé je
boxé et et j'allais quand j'habite à
angoulem j'allais à Poitier j'allais à
Bordeaux pour faire des castings une
fois une fois ah oui oh là
là une fois j'avais un casting à Paris
et ce qu'on devait faire c'est jouer le
la scène du miroir arrête
incroyable
par tu
parlesainain c'est tu parles c'est Mo tu
parles c'est
moi et j'arrive en casting je bon j'ai
pas été
rappelé mais je me souviens que j'ai
joué cette scène et c'est pour ça quand
j'ai su qu'on allait faire intervie je
ah trop marrant il faut que je rvoie la
vidéoon les preneo Vincent justement
dans le rôle d'Atos pour les duels
est-ce que vous êtes conditionné pour
ressentir une forme de pression aussi à
l'écran même si c'est totalement
différent en fait la particularité de de
filmer les combats dans les
Mousquetaires par Martin Bourboulon
c'est qu'en fait il voulait absolument
des plans séquences donc planans
séquence pour ceux qui ne savent pas
c'est donc un plan qui fait qui couvre
toute la scène et donc bah ça veut dire
que tu fais pas des tu fais pas des
coupes dans tous les sens où tu tu peux
te permettre donc il faut une fois que
c'est parti il faut il faut que ça aille
bien jusqu'au bout et il y a plein de
gens qui sont qui sont dans la scène
donc tu as la responsabilité de de pas
faire foirer le plan sinon tout doit
recommencer mais le truc c'est que du
coup il y a beaucoup d'adrénaline et du
coup on peut se faire mal en fait parce
que quand même même si les épées sont en
aluminium et pas en acier même si elles
sont elles sont avec des bourrons et
qu'elles sont pas tranchantes moi j'ai
découvert Cédric par exemple je pense
sur Instagram plus que la télé parce que
je regarde pas et puis après bon on
regarde et puis pu en a de plus en plus
c'est difficile de passer à tté du MMA
et puis c'est super jouiciif à regarder
en fait concrètement c'estàd que le MMA
on a même pas besoin réellement
d'être un pro du MMA pour pouvoir
comprendre ce qui se passe peut-être
dans la finesse plus mais quand il y a
des McGregor
des des mecs comme ça qui qui ont
tellement un truc de chaud et maintenant
Cédric aussi et et d'autres parce que
moi j'adore aussi Cyril Gan ce qui est
intéressant c'est que au-delà de la
capacité technique et sportive il y a la
personnalité du combattant et des fois
on est attaché à un combattant parce que
il a un truc entre le show et sa vie
personnelle j'en sais rien et c'est ça
que jeis dire quand tu as cité sur je
dire en fait chacun a son identité et
c'est ça qui fait qu'il y en a vraiment
pour tout le monde il y a des gens qui
vont détester et qui vont aimer un cyil
Gan et ou il y en a d'autres qui vont
aimer un Benoît saint ou un saladine
Parnas parce que il y en a vraiment pour
tout le monde et moi ce qui je rebondis
pour dire moi ce qui fait que j'aime
beaucoup Vincent c'est c'est que je
voyais beaucoup je me voyais en lui
avant même le sport moi je je veux être
acteur et c'est toujours un souhait
aujourd'hui d'être acteur et et je le
parallèle que je voyais en fait dans
dans nos deux carrières c'est bon comme
je l'ai dit la capacité d'adaptation et
le deuxième point c'est d'être en
quelque sorte le porte étandard bah de
de la France à l'étranger comme tu l'as
fait aux États-Unis et comme je le fais
comme je l' fait en Chine aux États-Unis
je le fais encore aujourd'hui et surtout
troisièmement intervie que j'avais vu de
toi où tu disais euh je sais je un atout
j'arrive toujours à l'heure je sais que
quand il a besoin de moi pour telle
scène je sais que peu importe même si je
suis dans la merde je vais la réussir la
scène et cetera et on pourrait sur dire
il se la pète un peu et en fait non
parce que c'est exactement moi ce qu' ce
qu'on me reprochait aussi c'est dire tu
te la pète alors que non quand je dis
par exemple que je suis meilleur qu'un
tel c'est que je le sais c'est pas je le
sais parce que je vais te le prouver si
tu veux je suis meilleur qu'un tel quand
je dis je vais mettre KO ce mec là il
peut pas tenir 5 minutes face à moi
c'est que je sais en fait par rapport à
aux efforts que je fournis à
l'entraînement par rapport à la connaiss
de moi-même tout simplement comme quand
tu dis je sais pas moi je sais que je
vais me débrouiller je sais que je vais
arriver à l'heure je sais que je vais
réussir cette scène parce que tu le sais
c'est pas vraiment un excès de confiance
et c'est ce parallèle que j'ai vu en N
et ça me faisait sourire parce que bah
c'est ça qui fait que j'aime beaucoup
donc en fait c'est ça peut-être ta
reconversion apr par fait tu fais déjà
l'acteur qu part c'est un jeu tout ça de
toute façon tu sais quoi la vérité je
c'est que c'est un jeu en fait et j'ai
même l'impression que la manière
d'évoluer aussi dans dans ce que tu fais
il y a un moment tu vois tu tu fais le
trash tu fais le truc tu tu déconances
le mec avec qui tu vas te tu vas
combattre tu vois c'est un truc à un
moment il y a c'est un c'est un un
spectacle c'est un jeu et tu as des
cartes tu joues tu es là tu ça passe là
tu viens derrière le mec tu tu lu dis
dans l'oreille ce qu'il doit dire à
l'arbitre c'est un peu un truc ça tient
sur toutes ces choses-là c'est pas des
maps est-ce qu'on peut avoir peur une
forme d'appréhension avant une scène
avant de monter sur scène moi j'ai peur
j'ai déjà dit hein moi j'ai vraiment
peur c'est le pire le pire moment c'est
dans les vesti dire moi le meilleur
moment moi c'est quand on annonce le
combat ah là je me régale je sais que je
vais dire plein de conneries de presse
ouais je conférence de presse même bien
avant quand on annonce au combat là je
me régale sur les réseaux sociaux je
fais je me régale en fait et le public
adore ça et le moment le plus où tout
mon combat va se jouer ça va être dans
les vestiaires je vais être assis les
bandes les bandages sont mis euh je suis
échauffé je suis en tenue et là tu as le
mec qui arrive avec son casque euh le
régisseur qui arrive que 30 minutes ça
qu'il arrive on attend un peu hop ah il
y a un KO faut y aller ah c'est là c'est
ça y est quoi mon dans l'AR prépare-toi
viens avec nous bon on se prépare tac ça
tu te sens bien bah ouais ça va vite non
quand même après une fois une fois que
ça commencé la sensation bon là ça va
vite en l'occurrence mais quand même-
que est-ce que tu as la sensation que le
temps tout d'un coup défile un peu tu es
tellement il se passe tellement de trucs
dans ta tête ça dépend si tu es dans ton
combat ou si tu es pas dans ton combat
en fait si tu fais une bonne prestation
ton combat il passe vite tu tu l'Enjoy
même si tu passes à côté de ton combat
c'est l'enfer sur toiême tu sais l'enfer
tu tu subis le combat tu tu te demandes
quand est-ce que ça va
s'arrêter c'est très très long c'est
très très long gens peuvent t'admirer
aujourd'hui ça te fait quoi bah en fait
ça me fait bizarre parce que parce que
bah parce que pour moi ce que je fais
c'est bon ouiah je mets des chos mais
enfin il y en a plein qui mettent des C
c'est pas c'est pas incroyable c'est
c'est juste c'est juste un sport de
combat et du coup le fait de voir ça
autour je me dis bon ok c'est ça fait
cet effet là d'accord et bah c'est ce
que tu dis quand tu vois un film bon tu
dis ouais ça film quoi alors quei
aujourd'hui je voir un film d'ailleurs
je vais te demander c'est quand tu vois
un film qu'est-ce qui va te euh
qu'est-ce qui va t'impressionner encore
aujourd'hui dans un film c'est ça va
être la proesse du Real la presse du je
sais pas le peut-être le producteur dire
produire un film comme ça énorme ou
alors les les jeux d'acteurs des acteurs
j'ai envie de te dire c'est quand la
sauce prend c'est quand tout l' coup tu
es là tu et en plus c'est horrible parce
que à force de faire tu vois je en une
bande annonce trois plans tu vois
per de travers la perruque la lumière
mal et après quand tu vois un truc bien
même tu sais pas ce qu' fait tu fais oh
[__] c'est quoi ça tout de suite tout
de suite je sais pas il y a un truc qui
se dégage c'est ça qui est fou avec le
cinéma en fait c'est que quand c'est
quand c'est quand c'est du cinéma et
quand c'est pas juste un truc PL les un
derrière les autres quand la prend c'est
pas juste un acteur dans un MAA film
même s'il est très bon ça reste un très
bon acteur dans un mavais film je
remercier tous les de
vent qui était super intéressci à toi
cool